on a pris une très très triste nouvelle
hier d'ailleurs on est ensemble avec
valérie quand on a appris la nouvelle
qui nous a énormément touchés et c'est
vrai que je pense qu'il aurait aimé
rigoler avec nous c'est rené malleville
notre ami celui qui fait partie de notre
famille qui a toujours fait partie de
notre famille depuis le premier jour où
il est arrivé dans l'émission supporters
aussi emblématique de l'olympique de
marseille il est parti et c'est vrai
qu'il est parti
s'il a été foudroyé par un par un cancer
du pancréas et du foie à l'âge de 73 ans
c'était vraiment je l'avais dit une des
plus belles recruter pmp depuis des
années des années on quand il venait on
était tous voilà tous autour de lui
parce que c'était celui qui nous faisait
le le plus marrer et bien sûr on tient à
présenter nos plus sincères condoléances
à ses proches ainsi qu'à sa famille et
on voudrait revenir ce soir sur les plus
beaux souvenirs qu'on a égrené on a
plein d'extraits de rené parce qu'on
voulait vraiment lui rendre un hommage
ce soir d'ailleurs on a laissé voilà une
chaise vide avec un maillot de l'om ce
soir c'est une idée de stéphane tapis
d'ailleurs voilà qui m'a donné l'idée
hier parce qu'il était aussi très très
touché par la disparition de rené comme
vous tous et c'est vrai qu'on a tous des
souvenirs avec avec rené on va en parler
dans un instant j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
d'extraits vous allez voir on va revoir
rené et rené je pense qu'ils voient là
il aurait aimé qu'on on se marre ce soir
voilà et qu'on rigole avec lui parce que
on s'est éclaté avec lui et toutes les
équipes je vous dis qu'ils sont même
hors plateau qui sont facto chronique
pas les chroniqueurs tous les gens qui
travaillent en prod hier il était
dévasté par la disparition de notre nez
on va revenir sur plein d'extraits de
rené on va lui rendre hommage dans un
instant et puis bien sûr ça va nous
donner vos meilleurs souvenirs à égrener
parce que je sais vous allez tous à
souvenirs avec rené malleville et on
pense très fort à sa famille et au vivat
la run et il va nous manquer il va
manquer à tout le monde parce que
c'était des personnages comme ça il y en
a napa et des personnages comme rené
vraiment manaia n'y en a plus il va il
va manquer à l'om il va manquer à touche
pas à mon poste il va manquer à sa
famille va manquer tout le monde et
c'est vrai que tout le monde m'a rendu
hommage il j'avais même sur les chaînes
info et ça m'a fait assez plaisir de
voir voilà qui avait beaucoup de chaînes
bfm ses news voilà toutes les chaînes
n'ont rendu en a eu vent de cet art est
elle dans le canal football club
également et les yankees l'histoire la
télévision a pour moi parce que on
parlait de rené malleville bien avant
qu'il soit dans l'émission c'est vrai
que c'est un personnage incroyable il
nous a quittés hier rené il été emportés
vraiment parra qu'en sait on avait vu en
août 1 qu' il avait mis un tweet qui
nous avait un petit peu inquiété et
c'est vrai que très vite ça s'est
dégradé pour lui sa santé s'est dégradée
et il va nous manquer rené j'avais
souvent par sms et c'est vrai qu'il nous
manquait dans tpm pays il va nous
manquer dans la vie alors on va vous
remettre un petit peu voilà des extraits
de rené ce soit on va revoir voilà c'est
cesser ses plus grands moments et pour
tout que ceux qui ne le connaissaient
pas pour ceux qui souffrent de sa
disparition vous a préparé un petit
magnéto pour vous présenter rené
malleville rené c'était ça
la bonne mère s'est réveillée avec la
tête lourde et le choeur 12 euros ce
dimanche matin à marseille
triste nouvelle le grand supporters de
l'om figure médiatique bien connu rené
malleville est décédé
on est mal ville 73 ans nous a quittés
il était pour tout le monde le supporter
est emblématique de l'om c'est animal de
test pour tous les marseillais
connaissent et nikon pour marseille
connu pour sa fameuse minute de rené qui
rassemblait chaque semaine des milliers
de fans
salut tout le monde c'est honteux et
bougez vous le cul ça pas les couilles
jouer le pire oui
on l'aimé pour ses coups de gueule
légendaires son franc-parler inégalable
et ses expressions caricatural à rené
aussi authentique à domicile qu'à
l'extérieur
en avril 2018 il rejoindra la famille
tpm paix pour nous offrir de grands
moments de bonheur
[Applaudissements]
si hier la cité phocéenne était bien
calme pour un jour de match au vélodrome
les supporteurs ont tenu à lui rendre
hommage
marseille compte désormais une deuxième
étoile qui brille raja mais dans le
coeur des français
[Musique]
on pense fort à la famille de rené un
bien entendu alors il ya bruno pomart
qui nous a rejoint bruno qui était un
proche un de rené quignard tu m'a écrit
tout de suite et c'est vrai que rené
cité mais c'est un bonheur je crois que
les images que tu as montré là et voilà
les représentent tout à fait le
personnage qui est érodée malville avec
cette gouaille ce cette passion qu'ils
avaient de l'om évidemment les du
football mais d'autres sports aussi le
rugby il avait une passion pour le
sahara ou aux sinois chaque fois compris
si c'est quelque chose avec les il ya un
élément que peut-être peu de gens en
colère c'est pour ça que je suis là ce
soir merci
d'éviter ça me touche beaucoup il était
natif de l'ordre il faut savoir il est
né à castres est exactement il est né à
carcassonne ray et vivait dans ce petit
village avec avec sa femme annie
d'ailleurs que je salue qui m'a autorisé
d'ailleurs a parlé un petit peu de sa
vie un petit peu en est sa femme mais
qui nous parlaient à venir histoire son
fils et qui doivent être dans une
immense tristesse terrible et sa femme
il en parlait tout le temps est vraiment
je vous dit on on était là on était fan
moi j'étais fan de lui il le sait que
j'étais fan de lui sans détour sans
détour quoi c'est direct c'est un
terrien ces gens du sud c'est au sein
même temps et c'est vrai comment j'ai
passé encore les derniers moments avec
lui à fin juillet j'ai mangé un
cassoulet avec ligne à picoler une
bouteille de vin rouge à côté de mon
petit village ensemble il faisait
transparaître y ait de la maladie ou
quoi ce qui est sa cession au dernier
moment et malheureusement ces partis
mais mais voilà on devait se revoir et
puis et on avait parlé évidemment
longues bandes puisque j'ai la chance
d'être sur btp aussi et devenir temps à
autre sur cette émission de parler de
toi évidemment ce qui t'a d'oreilles
beaucoup il m'a même fait venir dans son
petit dans sa petite maison de village
toute petite maison de village qu'il
adorait qu'il appartenait à sa famille à
son grand père et il m'a présenté
quelque chose qui avait offert ses
harmonicas tard avec un ep prêter tous
côtés humanitas à ces signes qui me l'a
offert voilà tiens mais voilà c'est
génial il ya un mois et demi voilà et
mais il le sait je vois là je le voyais
plein de petits mots voilà tout le temps
et c'est vrai que il manquait dans
l'émission il va manquer dans la ville
va nous manquer c'est vrai qu'on l'ait
on était ça a été un coup de coeur pour
nous vraiment rené mathieu je sais que
tu l'as doit aussi bah oui beaucoup on
avait rencontré la première fois c'était
à l'époque on était encore à aaa direct
8 1 était venu et on devait chaque
chroniqueur limité il nous faire son
coup de gueule à son machin et on avait
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
khoury parce que eux parce que parce
qu'il s'était énervé parce qu'on évite
et parce que le basketteur bat les
couilles et comme d'habitude quoi on
avait beaucoup ri était très touchant je
n'ai pas vu de dix mille fois dans ma
vie mais évidemment il est très touchant
alors hier l'olympique de marseille
jouait en fin d'après midi un match
contre rennes au stade vélodrome que ce
soit dans les tribunaux dans la ville en
général rené a eu un hommage à la
hauteur de l'homme qu'il était regarde
[Applaudissements]
ça fait beaucoup de peine à être
insupportable tous les grands supporters
de l'om le gars de rougeole dans leur
coeur je pense
c'est une image de test pour tous les
marseillais connaissent une icône pour
marseille je pense que c'est toute
pensée aujourd'hui qui attriste et de la
wii sera il pourra nous aider encore ea
à supporter cette équipe qui est qui
tenait très très cher à rené aujourd'hui
les icônes comme ça oui c'est assez rare
je pense y en aura d'autres mais il
marquera je pense de nombreuses
générations même l'année suivante a été
extraordinaire ils étaient ni c'était
une bête de télé en plus
il vit parce qu'il a été syndicaliste
alain thème est pas et pas des moindres
il ay la séquestrer le patron de rtl a
failli là ils avaient encouragée il a
été élu à mains nues temps de gaston
defferre et qui était maire assure est
un mec formidable avec plein de il était
soudeur chauffeur de bus à la régie des
transports marseillais il est ensuite
devenu un syndicaliste raid engagé avant
de se reconvertir en patrons de bars et
ses règles voilà c'était surtout une
paire de tennis valérie bénaïm chez que
vous étiez très triste de se dire oui
moi j'ai vraiment le coeur serré parce
que on a échangé ensemble avec rené
20 août wesh fin août et il me disait
qu'il allait se battre de façon il était
entouré enfin vous et moi
j'entendais sas est cette voix cette
gouaille qui est jésus lui dit mais bien
sûr que tu vas gagner bien sûr que tu
vas gagner donc bon bah voilà alors on
voudrait revoir la première de thé pmp
de première de rené dans tpm paix
c'était en 2018 regarder et à rené
malleville aujourd'hui parce qu'après le
lantus ou 10 h ils gardent
ce nouveau look et rené ont le kiff
ibragim à lui aucune maquette de colette
la démarche est comme ça à le gagner ou
perdre la face aussi doté de belles voix
qui va le pré va te fais pas mais les
140 heures tu me fais pas de souci pour
moi q r que pour
[Rires]
commencer qui avait pas de truc je m'en
fous du coup vu que j'ai pas regardé
[Applaudissements]
ça on s'est régalé il adorait toutes les
filles de l'équipe et ben justement et
c'est pour ça que des conneries soit ça
soit là soit parce que audrey en
logement vous les avez donné votre 06
m'a demandé mon 06 fait regarder on a eu
mal je ne sais pas
mais rené tu aurais plat de demander le
téléphone de audrey
audrey tu vas les jeunes et à peut-être
non
banon faire et les téléphones de mots
aussi derrière ta damien moreau est à
l'appât de mambé
guillaume elle et donne son numéro
6 6 allée de bordeaux ici
c'est vrai que c'était très chaleureux
il a vraiment une personnalité
authentique et le fond je sais que tu
l'adoré toi aussi moi je l'adoré mais
j'ai tout de suite je me suis très bien
entendu avec lui parce qu'il est
vraiment c'est quelqu'un de sain de ça
alors aussi rené c'était devenu un des
chroniqueurs emblématique de tpm paix
tout le qui fait d'apporter à l'émission
c'est vrai que sa bonne humeur son franc
parler surtout ses coups de gueule c'est
vrai qu'il en a fait des coups de gueule
dans l'émission et nous on se régaler
bref voilà moi j'ai eu des moments j'ai
eu des fous rires incroyable acronyme
divague dans l'interview il y avait le
pardon il
ya des gains qui comme paris je fais
comme qu'elle tarde à août pour ceux
restés à sauveur il passe dans la rue
klaxonnent mais y'a pas que les
marseillais dans le monde entier le
monde entier dans le monde
depuis samedi jamais les coûts et les
coûts télégramme de formation loana
c'est la plus grande star de france de
telit et il te rends compte que tu as lu
annulés qui te raconte qu'à la fin du
monde comme par le sol mais chabal et
coutumes et traditions c'est vrai que
par des cuisines et toi occupent eux
tendent à les mener les enquêtes de
loana
[Rires]
il est avec la toîle et un plateau comme
vous l'aviez là quand il est dans la vie
mais c'est ça joue pas un rôle est lancé
c'est rené quoi c'est clair il est il
est cash allant d extrader ses bisous à
toi tu étais très bonne voie alors moi
c'est devenu mon compagnon de ses soeurs
bmp6 tous les soirs tous les soirs on
aura une vie nous happer les deux vieux
du muppet show on s'asseyait et ont
regardé à prendre ou à laisser en
faisait des commentaires parlant de deux
heures quand j'étais en retard et ma
peine de l'été ou et il m'a offert ce
bracelet quelqu'un avait fait un de ses
amis qui est une balle une balle qui a
été retravaillé et même absent tu disais
mais il appelait visite une porte ce
bracelet paradigmatique le verra ce soir
elle me mettez bien ostensiblement comme
ça et je n'ai jamais quitté et je le
quitterai jamais mais vraiment jamais à
dos et c'est vrai que chaque fois ils
visaient des gens qui s sur vous mais
moi c'est mon compagnon au moins de la
vue un processus accéléré en quelques
mois et c'est vraiment quelqu'un et
merci infiniment de me l'avoir fait
comme je veux dire quand il a quitté tpm
p je me rappelle mon identité réussite
avec nous fit d'abord les primes petit
verre oui dans ma loge voilà tous
ensemble avec 3,4 au nikkei avait isaiah
veille avait raymond d'ailleurs oui et
on avait rigolé comme des oufs et c'est
vrai qu'il était on s'est éclaté quand
j'ai jamais vu un chroniqueur qui était
parti avec qui on a autant rigolé le
soir même de son départ parce qu'on
était chenilles on a pris un verre
d'emballage en a on n'a pas arrêté de
rigoler tt la mort et montera pas c'est
vrai mais si vous savez pourquoi on a
rigolé pourquoi vous avez plus à ce que
lui s'en foutait de l'argent il n'est
pas ici pour l'argent et qu'on a fait
pour elle pour dire ce qu'il avait envie
de dire sa cellule mais aussi une récré
pour lui et c'était quelqu'un de vrai
ici trichez pas et moi pourquoi j'adore
ces mecs là parce que ils ont toujours
quelque chose à dire il ya toujours de
la partie si tu lisais un truc il va te
répondre que quelque chose c'est qu'on
tue dix bêtes de télé c'est pas peu de
regret c'est la vie normale c'est un mec
normal c'est pas de bête de télé et moi
je me souviens quand a commencé à percer
en radio en 2010 et que tu as fait tes
pmp france cadets 8 déjà tu commençais à
aller chercher leur nation tu m'as
envoyé à marseille pour psg om il y
avait marseille psg tu m'avais dit va là
bas va voir rené malleville après j'ai
été le voir je les ai rencontrés une
première fois quand on a fait touche pas
à mon sport tu l'a ramené aussi à touche
pas à mon sport j'ai fait une caméra
cachée dans son bar j'aime asean de lui
je suis resté on était bourré tous les
deux jusqu'à 4 heures du matin on était
complètement mort je suis rentré à
l'hôtel j'ai pris le tgv directs moi
j'ai adoré ce mec là est pour vous dire
qui c'est rené malleville un jour il
m'appelle hilarant 2018 eh bien on
s'irrite tu te fous de ma gueule je suis
je suis en train d'arriver à gare de
lyon y a personne pour me chercher j'ai
dit mais c'est mais tu sais qui tu veux
qu'ils disent cyril hanouna je suis pas
de cyril hanouna moi je suis le ciridd
of china
tu peux rien faire pour moi cggv avec
loïc héloïse votre bras droit qui
qadisiya quelqu'un qui va chercher rené
c'était ça était capable de mélanger
numéro de téléphone avant moi ça m'a
fait de la peine parce que c'était
vraiment quelqu'un d'entier et c'est
arrivé tellement vite que cécile valeur
tout le temps de sa fin habitués ou
claniques histoire son fils et son fils
sont si
on venait à aussi avec rené on a eu
d'été nombreux fous rires inventé pmp on
avait beaucoup charrier avec le psg lui
qui était un grand fan de l'om et on lui
avait fait une petite surprise on avait
fait venir le professeur a aussi en
plateau en plateau ça a été un moment
franchement je crois que c'est un des
plus gros fous rires ça fait partie du
top 5 2 mais fou rire dans cheap trick
vous lirez votre poème au professeur ou
quand il va rentrer voilà merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui bien sûr
dégâts
[Applaudissements]
ça c'était ça c'était extraordinaire
mais sachez un de mes plus gros fous
rires mais moi ce que j'avais il avait
rigolé là dessus c'est quand il le
voyait d'abord en duplex qui
stoppa sur le professeur raoult et l'om
une fixation totalement non mais c'est
c'est c'était fou bernard il a manqué
bien sûr bien sûr parce que de tomber
qu'on avait nos end sa très belle
relation avec lisa notamment on était
souvent avec lui et en plus moi j'ai
demandé de ses nouvelles jusqu'au
dernier moment et puis à un moment je
sentais bien dans l'écriture que c'était
plus lui qui répondait aux textos
jusqu'à la fin c'était un de ses
collègues qui répondait et c'était fin
n'a compris que ça allait très mal se
passer ouais ce que j'ai rarement
rencontré un homme aussi authentique
dans tous damas et dans sa façon parler
de bouger de réfléchir de et d'aimer les
gens aussi fortement comme sa maman
quand vous lui donniez et il vous
donnait son amitié c'était très fort
parce qu'il m'appelait souvent j'étais
même très étonné qu'ils m'appellent
parce que voilà moi je ne suis pas en a
il des vies différentes et j'étais très
touché je l'aimé beaucoup alors y avait
une petite surprise aussi qu'on avait
fait un run est ce que vous rappelez
dans la grande rade sera en live oui
petit indice sarr concernés sa voiture
avait récupéré la voiture de redire
regarder
[Musique]
[Rires]
ok mais l'europe et
a fait gagner à tout public je le donne
à table tout public ouais mais tu me
rappelles aventure
[Rires]
gg et d'ailleurs quand il y avait
toujours des défis d'exciter pour des
associations il
vraiment répond oui non non c'est pas la
raison géraldine pour les associations
rappelez vous l'avez mis le bonnet du
son c'est très bien pour un marseillais
matin bonnet est-ce que vous rappelez du
fou rire de rené c'est après avoir une
séquence de l'indic de la rédac avec sa
chaîne base regardez
les tl cr
non quoi t'es chez les
rangs des gardes ne s'est pas
relâché
la victime à paris le samedi
matin dans l'hérault n'est pas ce que tu
me retourner tu me dis tu prennes 5000
euros si tu veux je sais je
me dis monsieur marieville à ce monsieur
de chabanais hynix cascales que je m'en
bats les couilles
et un boléro des bois très bien en tout
cas tu étais content qu'ils aient gagné
l'om
j
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c c'était comme un tir et encore une
fois il nous aimait vraiment moi je
crois tu ces images ça ça nous font de
coeur parce qu'il va vraiment nous
manquer ni au moins moi je suis vraiment
admiratif de son parcours vous l'avez
dit c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui a tout
fait dans sa vie soudeur conseil
municipal chauffeur de bus chroniqueur
télé et mme avec des analystes voilà et
malgré sa grande expérience y avait
beaucoup de second degré il aimait bien
pourri gaulle de lui et avec lui donc
sage truc c'était vraiment appréciable
parce que c'est lancé il aimait danser
ce que vous rappelez de sa danse sur
michael jackson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il avait il avait des projets de tv web
et ou encore il avait des choses il
voulait revenir habiter dans le petit
village de salles sur l'hers sa petite
maison si le jour tu viens dans le sud
que tu viennes sa femme et vous avez vu
aussi vous sa femme et son fils au
téléphone amie annie que parent par
textos mais encore une fois j'étais il
ya un mois et demi avec eux avec un cas
ni ses amis proches les martinez qui
sont des amis du village à côté bref et
c'est l'icône évidemment du village
puisque tout le monde mais il se prenait
pas pour une star du tout attention non
mais au bistrot tous sont passés des
sondés envoyé son dernier tweet il dit
je m'adresse aux millions de messages
reçus qui me font trop d'eau bien
m'excuser moi je ne peux répondre à tous
sachez que vous me donnez un courage
incroyable j'en ai besoin dans ces
moments là pensez bien que je ne vous
trouve je ne me trouve pas au mieux je
vous embrasse à tous des centaines de
milliers de gens qui l'ont suivi qui le
suivent toujours qu'on fait c'est
hallucinant c'est une vraie star c'est
vrai sinon c'est et c'est dommage sera
effective il va nous manquer à tous